he's been rescued from World War two
he's been rescued from the Gulf War he's
been rescued from the Middle East twice
he's been recovered from space more
space even more space and saved from
this terrible boston childhood it's not
your fault
now now Matt Damon will need to be saved
again in space again the Martian and
blast off to the red planet with the
Ares 3 and a crew of veteran movie
scientists including this scientist from
interstellar this scientist from
interstellar this scientist from fan
four stick and these two Marvel
sidekicks but when their mission is
threatened by an inciting incident Matt
Damon will be left behind to survive in
a barren wasteland with only his wits to
guide him and tons of stuff that's
already lying around from other Mars
missions like a space habitat a car an
extra car he can use for ports a camera
robot pressurized saran wrap and an
entire spaceship that can get him off
the planet come on
Tom Hanks needed was a volleyball and an
ice skate travel to a world where NASA
is suddenly super popular and fully
funded to meet potty-mouthed astronaut
Mark Watney to Mars I'm gonna have to
science the he's a skilled botanist Mars
will come to fear my botany power who
must survive the Red Planet on his own
using only his specialized knowledge of
plant biology to perform emergency
self-surgery
chemical engineering I take space
repairs alternate numerical systems
hexadecimals to the rest of spaceship
construction and wall-e age so he can
basically do everything man suck on that
Neil deGrasse Tyson and climb aboard for
a two-hour nasa commercial that really
wants you to know that signers are just
as cool as superheroes
I get to fly around like Iron Man we're
astronaut Matt Damon struggles to
survive the harsh Mars elements by
periscoping everything he's doing I know
what I'm gonna do everything he's
thinking what do you like the way it
sounds I'm gonna tell them everything
that happens to him so yeah I blew
myself up my balls everything he's
eating we looked at this potato and some
crushed vicodin and every song he
listens to I'm definitely gonna die up
there if I wanted an audio book I could
have just you know bought the audio book
and strap it in for a space adventure
filled with edge-of-your-seat realism
like math let's do the math 31 souls for
redundancy they sent 68 Sol's worth of
food that's for six people so for just
me that's gonna last 300 Sol's which I
figure I can stretch to 400 more baths
1,200 kilometres in diameter bearing 24
point 41 degrees 8,600 Newtons 7,500 126
square meters of soil and even more math
35 kilometres 912 Sol's 200 Sol's Sol
409 609 26 characters plus a question
card in the 360 gives us 13 degrees of
Arc whoa science fact makes science
fiction kind of boring starring the
Martian Murph
Abed Boromir joette old agiel of War II
she will see what she would teach us man
I give up and meth Damon cast away in
space
so could he turn off all those cameras
when he needed to you know do stuff to
himself because I mean he was up there a
long time right be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers hey screen junkies
we are hitting the Big Easy this
Saturday January 9th for Wizard World
New Orleans check the description below
for info on where to watch a live movie
fight an exclusive look at interns of
field and our first ever live honest
movie screening we'll see you there I
don't share your greed the only card I
need is the ace of spades the ace of
spades they got the mustard out
lick my flapjacks and I'll catch you on
the flippety-flip
I fell asleep on New Year's Eve and woke
up in another year I'm gonna have to
science the out of this